[Applause]
from overpowering battles to jawdropping
animations 2023 has brought us some of
the most astounding Showcases of power
in anime and it all starts with what
happens when lowkey characters push
their limits and face off against
formidable foes from soloing an entire
Dragon to firing an atomic bomb all by
themselves stay with us as we count down
the top 20 anime showcases of power in
2023 and number 20 on our list is one of
the best Slice of Life anime with action
better than most shown in series free
Ren where fre Ren and fern defeat
[Music]
qual at the start qu couldn't even
scratch both of them because of Fern's
Shield but what he didn't know was that
freen was preparing a little surprise
for him she uses his own attack and
One-Shots him after chanting it with one
word the anime's approach to World
building is just like mushoku tensei
it's instead of info dumping it nitpicks
a lot by making each interaction seem
realistic this approach known as show
don't tell definitely makes the
storytelling a lot better the scene also
serves as a demonstration of the magical
arms race which is the main concept in
the anime it may be new but it proved
itself to be a contender for the best
anime of the
year
next up is when the Black Knight makes
the queen his slave from am I actually
the
strongest no one's talking about this
anime and I hope they start to after
seeing this moment it first looked like
gelut had the upper hand and the odds
seem stacked against haruto but haruto
is unscathed by her every attack which
is really unexpected considering that
everyone thought the queen was the
strongest haruto's ruthless in this
battle is shocking because imagine
putting a slave color on the queen and
your biological mother this fight is
just a power move on haruto's part also
there's a reference to code gas with the
MC cosplaying as Louch which adds a
touch of humor to the somewhat brutal
moment haruto definitely didn't give the
queen a chance and she kind of deserved
it because of her personality it may not
be flashy or have Godlike animation but
this was a satisfying comeback for
haruto that proved that even in 2023
overpowered MC's are all always fun to
watch we've got a surprising entry from
am Manoa where the hero's party slays
borom napolitan in a returner's magic
should be
[Music]
special in the year
3636 the world faces a die threat in the
form of a deadly black fog that
annihilates all life that it touches at
this final moment with only one final
boss left to defeat a mere six Valiant
individuals remain out of the initial
150 million this was just from a sneak
peek of the first 5 minutes of the first
episode and it didn't disappoint the
animation quality may not be like your
traditional anime CGI is heavily
involved but it looks awesome anyway
especially that last attack they even
blew the dark sky away the way these
Heroes fought against what looked like
an overpowered enemy and one just goes
to show why they're the only ones left
alive if you've read The Source material
you know that this is a gem just waiting
to shine up next is one of the most
anticipated anime this 2023 ragna
unlocks his future powers in ragna
Crimson it starts with the PowerUp with
ragar falling into dreams of the future
where he encounters an older version of
himself after he awakens his full power
and abilities are on display as he
confronts grimwood world even if ragna
Crimson is an anime that doesn't have
that big of a fan base the way they
animated this battle is visually
stunning also the way ragna's ability to
freeze grimel just goes to show how
powerful he really is if you look at it
closely it's not that intense of a
battle but it's more like an execution
he manages to not only defeat grimel but
also save Leona in the process imagine
how powerful he'll be if he manages to
control all of this untapped power and
potential they definitely took some
inspiration from gone and they did it
right
now at number 16 we have the moment when
Oliver kills his teacher in reign of the
seven spell
[Music]
blades Oliver unveils his own Spell
blade which he inherited from his mother
and we all know someone who's driven by
Vengeance will definitely put on a show
this scene is so intense that Oliver
uses his powers to torture Grenville
with memories of of the pain he
inflicted on his mother but he didn't
stop there because he pushed it further
to the point where Grenville even begs
for Mercy also the fact that he can
easily defeat his teacher clearly shows
how overpowered he is when Oliver
finally decapitated him it shocked most
of us because we finally got to realize
that he wasn't messing around completely
different from those beta MC's however
this is just the beginning since there's
still a few people he needs to take out
one big highlight is Oliver's character
development where his transformation
from a seemingly ordin individual to a
determined and ruthless Avenger is
nothing short of a
masterpiece blasting her way into our
list is megumin's first explosion in her
own gonu subba spin-off
series feeling the pressure of the dire
situation there in megamid makes a bold
decision to finally learn her beloved
explosion magic what makes this moment
particularly exciting is that despite
never having used magic before Megaman
draws upon her Crimson Demon instincts
to understand how magic flows through
her body the buildup to her learning
explosion magic has been teased
throughout the series and it was
definitely worth it and when she finally
lets loose with her explosion magic to
obliterate those monsters it gives
longtime konosuba fans like me
goosebumps the animation is absolutely
stunning and the sound and voice acting
are definitely on point for this Scene
It captures the essence of what makes
gonu subba so enjoyable and it may be
hard to believe that this parody isekai
is one of the best animations in the
genre megga men's explosion magic has
become an iconic part of the series and
it definitely blows us away every time
she uses
[Music]
[Applause]
it while talking about animation let's
move on to the next entry muo destroys
gyoko in Demon
Slayer
when the cloudlike Demon Slayer Mark
appeared on his face we all knew it was
over for goo every time he unleashes his
Mist breathing technique especially the
fifth form sea of clouds and Haze it's
like watching a whirlwind of action he's
so fast and precise Yoko can barely keep
up it's like he's living a blur and the
way he slices apart yoko's tentacles
with that technique it's a visual
spectacle that's just mindblowing you
can practically feel the agility and
swordsmanship oozing out of the screen
making it a truly captivating and
dynamic sequence there's no doubt that
when it comes to animation Demon Slayer
is always number one from the Mist to
the lightning I doubt we can see that
level of qualtity in other anime michiro
showed gyoko why he's the fastest and
youngest Demon Slayer to become a
hashira but his head was already on the
ground before he could even realize
[Music]
it next up is a Chinese anime Blaze of
the Guardians dma's
[Applause]
introduction at this moment dalar takes
the initiative by immediately attacking
and pinning down the hand of the Bandit
leader his Swift Maneuvers and precise
attacks quickly tip the scales in his
favor putting the Bandits on the losing
side the way they use the environment
was one of a kind making the scene feel
more Dynamic but what makes daar's
fighting style true truly remarkable is
his precision and brutal efficiency his
attacks are not only well executed but
very deadly taking out every Bandit one
by one the scene felt fluid and
thrilling and the choreography was on
point it showcases the potential and
quality of Chinese 2D animation and how
It's Quickly catching up to Japanese
anime dhar's battle against the bandits
is undeniably satisfying it's an
exceptional Showcase of Power Precision
and bloody combat that left viewers with
one hell of an impression
slowly approaching our top 10 is when
rudus solos a red dragon in mushoku
tensei season
2 rudia spends two years adventuring
with soat stepped leader party honing
his skills and reputation his journey
culminates in an epic battle where he
single-handedly takes on on a red dragon
this one quick execution just shows us
how powerful rudius has become as an
adventurer rather than opting for flashy
or wasteful spells he chooses the most
effective strategy to incapacitate the
dragon the final moments where he uses
Quagmire to immobilize and ultimately
defeat the dragon were just
disrespectful and it even ended up
dropping a huge Stone pillar on its head
what makes this scene truly impressive
is the animation and its ability to
convey the scale and impact of both
rudus spells in the dragon itself you
can feel the power and intensity of the
battle making it immersive to the point
that even the camera can't seem to keep
up with their movements it may have
happened in less than a minute but it
was refreshing to see an MC finally use
a practical approach rather than a grand
and flashy Display of
Power moving on to the next entry we
have the moment where fukui Reveals His
True power in Bongo stray dog season 5
the initial confrontation between
atsushi and Aku Dava against fukuchi is
one of desperation as they find
themselves outmatched by fukui's
formidable abilities his ritual sword
ameno Goen is revealed to be capable of
compressing space and sending the blade
to a different location up to a dozen
cenm away imagine being in a fight where
you wouldn't know where your enemy is
and you can never anticipate where the
sword will appear arm meno goes in in
can also manipulate time allowing fukui
to redo the past which adds another
layer of complexity to the mindboggling
one-sided fight at this moment fukui
seemed invisible because no matter what
they did when he could manipulate time
itself all their efforts were
wasted entering our top 10 we have baky
versus
yujiro
[Music]
this fight between Father and Son is a
unique and brutal lesson in strength and
combat the most fascinating aspect of
this scene is how it actually managed to
capture the true essence of the series
when it appears to be an allout brawl
it's also a unique form of bonding and
understanding between Father and Son as
the battle rages on it becomes clear
that B's ultimate goal isn't just to
defeat his father but to enforce his
will upon him it wasn't a one-sided
Display of Power but both of them shined
In This Moment the way the fight ended
is just so confusing for us normal
people in more ways than one it showed
us just how bizarre the world of bky is
and how complex of a relationship bakky
has with his father however we finally
get to see the ending we've all been
waiting for as yujiro acknowledges bky
to be the strongest it's kind of
heartwarming in a weird way at number
nine is the magic revolution of the
reincarnated princess Aris versus the
Dragon the way arnest and eilia work
together in this one is truly remarkable
facing off against a formidable Dragon
midair is no small feat although Anice
is armed with her magic gadgets a dragon
is no pushover especially if it can
Shield itself from her attacks after
sending AR is tumbling from the sky
fortunately for her eilia comes to her
rescue both of them combine their magic
in order to pierce the barrier of the
dragon and it was nothing short of
outstanding their coordination is on
point and theyve certainly become one of
the best Duos in 2023 they showed us the
true meaning of girl power because even
when arnice was equipped with modern and
Powerful magical tools she still
couldn't defeat the dragon headon which
says that it was definitely strong to
the point that it can obliterate a town
with its fire breath hey you know what
you can consider this fight as a fight
between modernity and an ancient
powerful creature and if you watched
gate you always know gunpowder
wins punching his way into the list is
Mash's entrance exam from mashall Magic
and
muscles it may look familiar because
you've probably seen it from one punch
man instead of relying on Magic like
everyone else he just uses his sheer
physical strength to Breeze through the
challenges I mean we're talking lifting
Boulders and running on water without
breaking in a sweat no spells needed
it's simply comedy gold The Examiner is
left scratching his head because Mash's
straightforwardness seems like he's just
lazy at first lemon even starts trying
to sabotage him but it's like they're in
a character development worldwind
because he even saves her at the end
it's a light-hearted and comedic moment
that really drives home the unique
approach Mash takes to Magic just how
overpowered he really is when it comes
to Pure strength it's not a series that
takes itself too seriously but it does
the
job
moving on to number seven we have the
misfit of the Demon King Academy Season
2 anos kills
[Music]
AOS the final fight had a mix of
surprising and maybe even some
anticlimactic elements especially when
you think about all the buildup during
the season we're all geared up for this
epic showdown and then arnos in true
opmc fashion just one shots Aros right
in the chest it's all over in the blink
of an eye well at first Aros seems to be
at an advantage but if you look closely
you'll notice how Carefree Aros is then
there's arnos vod's purple eyes and
they're no joke it's a game changer and
it's clear that once he activates them
things are pretty much settled all of
these clearly show how overpowered Aros
is in his own verse Aros is a true
ancient Demon King so just from that
Aros clearly doesn't stand a chance it's
impressive that even aran's order and
eyes of the Apocalypse can't hold a can
to it and what's truly terrifying is
that this version of his eyes is already
weaker compared to his original ones so
just imagine what would have happened if
he had
those now let's talk about one of the
most thrilling one-on ones in anime in
2023 the battle between Prince of funny
bunny and Mary Leona Vermilion in Black
Clover
it's one of those clashes that leaves
you in awe of the power and action on
display what truly sets this bachelor
part is that it's a one-on-one allout
brawl there are no handicaps and no
one's interfering it's just prin and
Mary Leona going at it fans already knew
Mario leono was a Powerhouse but this
fight took the intensity to a whole new
level the action sequences were a
masterclass and the animation quality
was off the charts it's like the entire
animation budget of Black Clover since
season 1 was given given entirely to
this movie in this fight Mar o Leona
truly proved her reputation showing her
prowess and unwavering tenacity you
couldn't help but see similarities
between Mario Leona and Ken Bachi zanaki
from Bleach both having a love for
combat and that never back down attitude
but prinia was no pushover because she
was also a former wizard King and her
magic could make her single-handedly
destroy entire kingdoms those two were
going at it like there was nothing else
going on in the world and we enjoyed
every second of it
gracing the top five is probably the
fans favorite Luffy versus kaido in one
piece Luffy straight up used Looney
Tunes to defeat kaido he did everything
from entering his belly and then
inflating himself to becoming a giant
grabbing lightning turning kaido into to
a jump rope and even hitting him with a
fist the size of Oni gashima it made it
clear to everyone in one piece that
Luffy isn't to be underestimated gear
five brought a whole new flavor to the
series that we've never seen before in
any other anime their battle was epic
with even different animators being
involved in this one fight this scene
truly captures what odar wants about one
piece as well as the cultivation of all
of Luffy's hardships it's a fantastic
blend of power and humor and it's
without a doubt one of the moments that
will definitely itch in your mind
there's a reason why everyone watches
one piece even though it has 1,000 plus
episodes and it's for moments like this
next up on our list is when Gojo used
his domain expansion in the shabuya
arc Gojo's decision to use the 0.2
second unlimited void is so unexpected
considering most jiujitsu Sorcerers
value human lives you'd probably think
that this will tie his hands but Gojo is
really him you must be thinking that he
calculated that move but oh boy you're
so wrong he did all of it just by his
own Instinct as he identified the
limitation of non Sorcerers around him
in that minuscule time frame he
calculates on what to do and how to do
it without leaving any adverse effects
to those who were hit by his domain he
isn't some superhero but he's Gojo
satoru and he's willing to do anything
to win even in that small time frame it
still has drastic effects on ordinary
humans because it would take at least 2
months before they recovered as they
received literally half a years worth of
information moreover the fact that he's
maneuvering around all the non Sorcerers
so fast is simply pure Madness in 299
seconds he massacred 1,000 transfigured
humans that isn't a Showcase of power
then I just don't know what is Gojo just
proved to everyone again that he
deserves to be called the strongest
sorcerer
alive
let's move on to our top three hell's
Paradise gabimaru versus tensen
what the battle between Gabby Maru and
tensen is nothing short of intense
tensen regenerative abilities add an
element of unpredictability to the fight
making it challenging for gabim Maru to
gain the upper hand what makes this
truly exceptional is the clarity in the
depiction of the action the choreography
and animation allow the audience to
follow every step and defensive move
with ease those exchanges seem to be
like the most brutal hand-to-hand combat
that you're ever going to watch they
were holding their ground against each
other despite all the punches and they
weren't even trying to dodge hands down
to garim Maru where even if he already
lost Consciousness his blows still
managed to tear 10 cent apart just like
yujiro and baky this was a complete back
and forth where each side seemed to have
the upper hand at some point or another
however Gabby Maru used everything he
had left in his tank to win and show 10
who the true monster was in the fight
although hell's Paradise did have some
inconsistencies when it came to
animation this was one of the highlights
of the entire series and it's just the
beginning and we're finally bound to the
top two with shadows I am Atomic in
Eminence in
Shadow Shadow's realization that he
needs to become nuclear to survive a
nuclear bomb sets the stage for a high
stake Showdown zenon's attempts to stop
him with his swords only add to the
anticipation however when Shadow's
Almighty power is Unleashed with the
Declaration I am Atomic the impact is
both cringe inducing and chilling the
voice actor did a fantastic job in
delivering those three iconic words they
managed to make it edgy and somewhat
cringy but at the same time it carries a
chilling and imposing presence which is
the whole point of the series the
explosion that follows is a testament to
the magnitude of Shadow's Newfound
nuclear abilities because it just leaves
a massive crater dis ability is
basically a game cheat code and if
you're his enemy what can you even do at
this point facing against a nuclear
blast is definitely suicide and there's
no way in hell you'll still be alive
after tanking an attack like that it's
truly a world shaking attack in his
verse and it makes you wonder how his
enemies will counter this kind of attack
everything else like the music and
animation added up to make this one
legendary moment
I
um
at last but definitely not least the the
entry that sends Tremors all over the
verse which is also the talk of the
anime Community senu Shas Bankai in
bleach in the Thousand Year blood War
there's no doubt that UA's Royal Guards
are incredibly powerful and who are the
ones to face them well it's Soul Society
strongest Squad zero it's said that
they're stronger than the entire goate
13 in a final bid to win against the
quincies they used their Bankai but to
prevent their immense spiritual pressure
from destabilizing the universe they
broke the Blood Oath seal sacrific three
members and open senum maru's full
potential when she activates her Bankai
she shook the world of the living the
soul society and quo Mundo which goes to
show that they weren't kidding this
scene gave Justice to Squad zero since
they were offs screened in the manga
this was only one bank eyy and it shook
all three worlds so what would happen if
all four of them activated their Bank
eyes at the same time senum maru's
Bankai was as beautiful as it was deadly
it was so strong that UA's Royal Guards
were completely pinned down by it and
were completely wiped out the animation
was Godlike and everybody was speechless
because we didn't expect to see
something like this she single-handedly
defeated the strongest enemy Soul
Society has faced and if it wasn't for
UA the quincies would have been
annihilated and there you have it our
top 20 anime Showcases of power in 2023
are there any amazing scenes that I
missed share your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to hit that
like button if you enjoyed this
countdown don't forget to subscribe for
more exciting anime content and I'll
catch you in the next video